dresden an der elbe historische bauten
aus renaissance barock und aus dem 19
jahrhundert prägen das stadtbild
wegen seiner prächtigen architektur die
sich an italienischer baukunst
orientierte wird dresden auch als
elbflorenz bezeichnet dresden hat eine
wunderbare altstadt mit verschiedensten
tollen museen die zu den
weltbekanntesten sammlungen gehören die
in den staatlichen kunstsammlungen ihr
zuhause haben eine tolle oper mit der
semperoper die semperoper am
theaterplatz ist das musikalische
wahrzeichen der stadt das bauwerk wurde
nach plänen des deutschen baumeisters
gottfried semper errichtet nur rund 650
meter entfernt steht dresdens
berühmtestes wahrzeichen die
frauenkirche im zweiten weltkrieg 1945
komplett zerstört wurde sie durch ihren
wiederaufbau ein symbol für frieden und
versöhnung der kunsthistoriker klaus
kemmer erklärt besuchern die stadt die
frauen kamen im grunde als das zentrum
der stadt eigentlicher betrachten also
das sind ihr wirklich dir
der auf die bestens jahr von dieser
krieg zerstörten stadt zum einen neuen
mit rola unweit der frauenkirche zeigt
der sogenannte fürstenzug sachsens
könige und kurfürsten darunter dresdens
berühmtester herrscher august der starke
ihm hat die stadt eine umfangreiche
kunstsammlung und zahlreiche
prachtbauten zu verdanken etwa den
zwinger das bauwerk ist einem römischen
amphitheater nachempfunden
beim singer sind wirklich in der
glanzzeit dresdens angekommen im 18
jahrhundert die zeit von august dem
starken
shokof ist axel könig von polen und er
den finger bauen lassen als einen
prächtigen raum eigentlich wo er sich
selbst inszenieren konnte in großen
festlichkeiten im zwinger sind auch
museen untergebracht darunter die
gemäldegalerie alte meister
die sammlung beinhaltet rund 3000
kunstwerke darunter schätze wie die
sixtinische madonna von raffael ein
meisterwerk der italienischen
renaissance dresden hat viele
sehenswerte museen dazu zählt auch das
albertinum
hier sind gegenwartskunst und eine
bedeutende skulpturen sammlung zu sehen
gleich gegenüber die kunsthalle im
lipsiusbau mit ständig wechselnden
ausstellungen
aktuell werden flämische landschaften
von beutel bis ruhms gezeigt
die stadt dresden beherbergt ja eine der
ältesten und umfassenden sammlungen an
kunst überhaupt der italienischen
niederländischen französischen deutschen
und spanischen malerei seit dem
sechzehnten jahrhundert
ein spannender kontrast zu all der
pracht dresdens äußeren neustadt in dem
szeneviertel gibt es viele cafés design
manufakturen clubs und galerien wie hier
in der kunsthof passage mit ihren
hinterhöfen die äußeren neustadt beim
immer schon ein viertel für kleine leute
sag ich mal einfache kleine wohnungen
es gab auch günstige mieten dass er ganz
viele studenten angezogen junge kreative
leute dorthin gegangen
sie wollte nicht den plattenbau viertel
leben der innenstadt gab es keine
wohnung und dann ist da dieses kleiden
szeneviertel dann eigentlich entstanden
ein neuer anziehungspunkt für
kulturliebhaber kreative soll das
ehemalige heizkraftwerk im stadtzentrum
werden
eröffnung ist im dezember wo einst wärme
und strom produziert wurden stehen bald
kunst und kultur im mittelpunkt unter
anderem bekommt hier dresdens
staatsoperette einen neuen spielort
[Musik]
für die stadt dresden ist musik
natürlich schon immer besonders wichtig
gewesen in der monarchistischen zeit war
das schon eine musikmetropole und es war
natürlich aber auch in der ganzen
bürgerlichen und protestantischen zeit
eine große musik metropole dresden eine
wahre schatzkammer an der elbe